So I’m working on a Horror History script
about a villain who has sparked a lot of debate among fans
with many people takingthis villain’s side and saying that this person was actually justified.
I’m not readyto say who this person is yet, but it got me thinking...
Are there any villains who wereactually doing the right thing?
So I put up a post asking my audience for input, challengingyou guys to name a villain who was in the right.
And I also spent the day thinkingabout it, and basically decided…
uh no, if they were in the right then theywouldn’t be considered the villain. Right?
But after mulling this over a littlefurther,
I do think there may be a couple villains who qualify.
To find outwho, stick around to the end of this video.
♪ Metal Music ♪
So then I started thinking aboutthe villains that came to mind,
and looking at some of the answers you guysprovided, I started seeing a few trends.
There were a few different categories that allof these villains seemed to fall into.
But let's lay down the technical definitionsbefore continuing.
So a villain is a character whose evil actions or motives are important tothe plot.
The protagonist is just the leading character in a work of fiction, and theantagonist opposes that leading character.
Usually the antagonist is the villain, but insome cases, the protagonist is the villain.
I went into this video thinking that therewouldn’t be any examples of villains who I found to have actions that were just…
butsome of these characters surprised me.
Justas you were probably surprised that I finallyuploaded something other than Horror History.
Also, seeing as how this *isn’t*an episode of Horror History,
I won’t go too in depth about any of thecharacters that I talk about here, but theremay be spoilers for the following stories.
Primarily, Gone Girl and Cabin in the Woods.
So with that out of the way let'sjump into the first category.
♪ Hard Rock Music ♪
In my post, there was one characterwho was the overwhelming favorite inthe replies
and that was CarrieWhite from Stephen King’s Carrie.
–[Carrie] It was bad Mama. They laughed at me.
To which I have to say… are you kidding me?
CarrieWhite was not in the right.
Now I did kind of baitpeople by putting her in the image, but still!
Thefact that so many people chose her is kind of concerning!
Carrie is a teenage girl who is abused athome by her overly religious mother while
being bullied and socially outcast at school byher cruel classmates.
When Carrie hits puberty,it coincides with an awakening of hertelekinetic powers, so when one of her
classmates orchestrates an extremely cruel prankby dumping pig’s blood on her at the Senior Prom,
Carrie snaps, kills her classmates and thenrampages into the the town and massacres it,
starting a huge fire and telekinetically twisting
the fire hydrant lug nuts so tight thatthe fire department could not access the water.
Now I’m not saying that Carrie is pure evil, andthe people who bullied and abused her are perfectangels.
They can both be bad, and they are. Buttwo wrongs do not make a right.
If someone doessomething to you, and you do it back to them, you’re now on the same level.
But Carrie is even worse than that because she not only got revengeon her bullies, but also killed innocent people.
Attacking in self-defense is OK, but that’snot what’s going on here.
If we were to taketelekinetic abilities out of the equation for amoment, this is essentially a school shooting.
Nobody is out there saying that the Columbineshooters did the right thing by shooting uptheir school because they were bullied.
Sowhy are people saying that about Carrie?
I’m guessing it’s because, in the movie, the storyis told from Carrie’s point of view.
We see thebullying, and I think it’s normal to feel bad forher. I’m guessing a lot of the people who said
Carrie have been bullied themselves at some point,and they are able to share in her frustration and
want to protect her because they relate to herin some small way.
And I think there’s just a little bit of disconnect here. I can understandthinking the antagonists deserved some kind ofpunishment
and maybe some people got that mixedup with saying that Carrie was in the right.
There were several answers that I put under thissame category of “they deserved it tho”.
Amazing Amy Dunne from Gone Girl staged her disappearanceto make it look like her husband had killed her
to get back at him for his infidelity, but shealso murders an innocent guy who took her in.
Another example is Frankenstein’s monster fromMary Shelley’s Frankenstein.
The monster wascreated by a scientist named Victor Frankenstein,obsessed with the idea of creating life.
Maybe just get a GF, my guy. Repulsed by hiscreation, Victor abandons the monster,
who then tries to connect with other humans,who are afraid of him, causing him to becomebitter and violent.
It’s OK to feel bad for themonster, who didn’t ask to be brought into this
world where he would be rejected, but Ican’t fully justify hurting other people.
I would be more willing to acceptFrankenstein’s Monster as a villain
that was in the right than Carrie White,because you could make the argument thatthe monster didn’t know better.
But thenyou start getting into the territory of,
“maybe the monster is not the villain.” Maybe*Victor Frankenstein* is the villain, the man
who tried to play God by creating life, but failedto take responsibility for what he had created.
You could argue that Victor Frankenstein was avillain who was in the right though.
After all,he was just trying to advance humanity throughscience. Sure he made mistakes, but it was in thepursuit of knowledge.
If we consider him to be thevillain, he would fall into a different category.
♪ Opera Music ♪
Elijah Price was a boy born with a conditioncalled osteogenesis imperfecta.
His bones were extremely fragile, so he spent mostof his life broken and in wheelchairs.
–[Elijah] They called me Mr. Glass.
While he was physically very fragile,he was extremely gifted from a mentalstandpoint.
He theorized that if someonelike him exists on one end of the spectrum,
there must be a hero who is incrediblydurable on the other end.
He carries outa series of terrorist attacks in search ofthis person, eventually finding a man named
David Dunne who is the only survivorof a trainwreck caused by Mr. Glass.
He spends the rest of the story encouragingDavid to take on the role of a superhero.
When one of you guys suggested himas a villain who was in the right,
it was because he madesacrifices with a noble goal,
and discovered an actual superherowho would go on to protect the city.
The villains in this category mostlyall fall under the same moral dilemma.
It’s basically a more complicated version ofthe infamous trolley problem.
If five people are tied to one side of the track,and one person is tied to the other,
is it OK to pull the lever and kill theone person in order to save the five?
According to tokresource.org, about 90% ofpeople would pull the lever and kill the oneperson to save the five.
So that settlesit, Mr. Glass was in the right… right?
– ACKCHYUALLY, allow me to correct you.
The trolley problem only has two options, pullthe lever or don’t.
Well, I always like to sayyou could pull during the merge point, andderail the trolley. Depends if anyone’s onthe trolley and how fast it’s going.
But mypoint is, if I were in Mr. Glass’s position,
and I believed there was a superhero out there whoneeded to be discovered, I wouldn’t settle for aplan that involved killing other people.
He couldhave just gotten involved in contacting survivors
of the many accidents that *already* happen,or held some kind of amateur sports tournament.
There are definitely less evil ways he could havegone about it. But he essentially wanted to be thevillain,
because in his comic books, the heroand villain are opposites in almost every way.
Mr. Glass wasn’t in the right, but I thinkwe are getting closer.
Our next villain alsotook up the diabolical podium out of what he sawas necessity. But the stakes were much higher.
(IMPACT)
♪ Upbeat Music ♪
Lelouch Lamperouge from Code Geass wanted tooverthrow the oppressive Britannian Empire,
but makes many morally questionable sacrificesto do it, including controlling others,
committing acts of terrorism,and betraying his friends.
–[Lelouch] What do you mean there’s only soup?
–[Suzaku] It means there’s only soup.
– [Lelouch] Well then get out of the soup aisle!
– [Suzaku] Alright, you don’t have to shout at me!
I love how there are gonna bepeople who watch this video
who have never seen Code Geass and theynow think those are their actual voices.
– [Lelouch] WHAT DO YOU MEAN YOU’RE AT SOUP?
A couple of you brought up Joseph Seedfrom Far Cry 5.
Joseph was essentiallya cult leader who believes he waschosen by God to gather followers
and lead them to “Eden’s Gate” to protectthem from the incoming apocalypse.
However,he’s willing to use violence and torture toadvance his goals.
At one point he pinchesthe tube on his own daughter’s life support,to kill her and prove his devotion to God.
Under normal circumstances, he’d be seen asyour run of the mill religious extremist,
no better than some of the worstterrorists of our world.
However,in the end, the apocalypse actually happensjust as he predicted, down to the very moment,
making it seem as if Joseph reallywas receiving the word of God.
Given that information, it’s hard to say thathe wasn’t in the right.
Any of the evil actions that he took before this point don’t reallymatter.
Everyone who wasn’t a follower ofhis would be wiped out anyways, so the guydid what he had to do to save humanity.
The story has an interesting message, because thereligious extremists of our world probably do
believe that they are serving God, and dosee their evil actions as heroic.
I thinkJoseph Seed forces the audience to see theworld through their eyes.
How do you dealwith these people when they see themselvesas divine?
It’s an interesting quandary.
Disclaimer, although I do think Joseph is oneof the best examples of a righteous villain,
I am not condoning any kind of religious violence.
I don’t want to see any news articlesabout the CZsWorld pipeline, OK?
The world of superheroes offers a couple otherexamples of villains in this category.
PoisonIvy from Batman engages in acts of terror indefense of the environment.
Thanos partook in what amounts to a mass genocide by snappingaway half of all life in the universe, which he
sees as a virtuous act to curb overpopulationand reduce strain on the world’s resources.
I hope I got that right. I’m not actually in theknow when it comes to the world of Marvel,
but Ido know a little bit about Thanos just by beingso into internet culture.
I mean -- the Thanoscar? f*cking hilarious.
Ant Man’s plan to defeatThanos? One of the best things I’ve ever seen.
Now when I was making my list, there weresome characters that I ended up moving intoa sub-category.
They weren’t just sacrificingjustice in the name of something they believe in,
they were taking justice into theirown hands. These are the vigilantes.
In the series known as Death Note,Light Yagami was a high school student
who happened upon a notebook that hadthe power to kill anyone whose nameis written into it.
After testing iton a criminal who had taken hostages,
he’s horrified by its power and resolves toget rid of it… but then he has another idea.
Light is going to use the notebook totake out ALL of the world’s criminalsso that only the good remain.
He wants tocreate a new world, a utopia with no badpeople or crime.
This approach is popular,and Light, or as he becomes known, “Kira”,
amasses followers all over the worldwho realizes someone is dishing out
punishment to criminals and supports hisendeavor. Others see him as just as bad or
worse than those he is killing, and seek to
hunt down and arrest this new serial killer.
The debate in the series has extended to reallife,
with fans arguing over whether Light was
a good guy or a bad guy nonstop in the 20
years since the series came out.
As a fan,I’ve spent a lot of time thinking aboutthis series, so it’s easy for me to see
that while Light has good intentions,
it is evil for any one man to be judge,jury and executioner.
The legal system hassplit these roles up for a reason.
Having one person handle all three is too much power,and that leads to corruption, which is exactlywhat happens to Light.
One person’s judgment cannever be unbiased, and may not always be fair.
Vigilante Justice stories are something of agenre of their own. Billy from Silent Night, Deadly Night
similarly targeted those whowere naughty before Christmas.
Clyde Sheltonfrom Law Abiding Citizen took revenge oncorrupt police officers and criminals who
were involved in the mis-sentencing of the manwho killed his wife and daughter.
Similarly,Dexter Morgan from the TV series Dexter, wasa forensics specialist by day, and serialkiller by night,
only going after heinouscriminals who had escaped the legal system.
Then there’s John Kramer, or ashe’s more commonly known, Jigsaw,
from the Saw franchise, who subjected his targets
to agonizing torture devices which he believed
would reinvigorate those who had lost their
appreciation for life… assuming they survived.
Don’t worry, the video’s not over.
Perhaps the best example in the wider “MadeSacrifices For The Greater Good” category would
be The Director from The Cabin in the Woods,the head of a secret organization whose goal
is to sacrifice five human archetypes toa race of ancient Gods living underground,
in order to entertain them and satisfy aritual.
If the ritual fails, the AncientOnes
will rise up and destroy the earth, sothe organization puts a lot of resources into
creating monsters capable of terrorizingand killing the young subjects.
It’s hardto argue against what the Director and therest of the organization are doing here,
because they’re literally saving theworld the only way they know how.
However, they may also fallmore into another category.
♪ Ragtime Music ♪
One of the top answers to my query outside of
Carrie White… which… occupied the top three spots,
was Parker Crane -- also known as
The Bride in Black from Insidious.
As a boy, Parker was abused by hismother, Michelle, who forced him to
dress up like a girl because she didn’t likehim going by the name his father gave him.
–[Michelle] THAT IS NOT YOUR NAME! PARKERis not your name!
That is thename your father gave you!
Your name… is Marilyn.
What’s the clinical name for this type ofbehavior? Oh yeah. She kinda cray-cray!
In life, she forced Parker to do horrible things,basically molding him into a serial killer.
–[Parker] If she sees you, she’ll make me kill you.
Even after she died, she continued to manipulatehim from the afterlife realm known as The Further.
After she’s eradicated from The Further,
Parkerbasically just fades away. Parker did do evilthings,
but he was controlled from such a young
age, and the grip was kept on him for so long,
that it almost seems like it was unavoidable.
Youcould make the argument that Michelle is the main
villain here, and I would agree with that,but Parker is technically a villain as well,
as per our definition. I also have a special spot
for Parker because my Black Bride video was the
one where I did the fake brand deal for tap water,
which is one of the dumbest gags I’ve ever done.
–[CZ] Make sure to use code CZsWorld. You can justsay it out loud whenever you turn on the faucet.
And as much fun as that was,
it didn’t exactly pay the bills. Sohopefully this does. We got an ad break.
(IMPACT)
♪ Suspenseful Music ♪
Jack Torrance is the main antagonist from TheShining. Jack is a teacher and father asked
to take the job of the winter caretakerat The Overlook Hotel. But The Overlook
Hotel is haunted, and Jack is possessedto go crazy and try to kill his family.
(Wendy screaming)
– Here’s CZ!
I actually said that at a Halloween partythis year, after showing up dressed like this.
Note: you could make the argument for both
versions, but the book version gives a heavier
implication that Jack was possessed.
WhenDanny has his final confrontation with him,
he seems to realize this and says,
“You’reit, not my daddy. You’re the hotel.
And when you get what you want, you won’t
give my daddy anything because you’reselfish"
And after Jack regains controlmomentarily, he tells Danny to run away.
Somebody in the comments had another suggestion.
“I’m gonna skip the obvious ones and
say the mom from The Babadook.
They did WAY too good of a job makingthat kid the whiniest and mostunbearable child.
Sorry but I can’t blameher reaction for most of the movie 🤷🏼‍♀️”
That’s a pretty funny comment,
because he’s framing this to fit intothe “They deserved it tho” category…
♪ Hard Rock Music ♪
which may be deserved.
(Sam screaming)
…but realistically, we also gotta
consider the Puppet Villain category.
♪ Ragtime Music ♪
Amelia, the mother in the Babadook is entrancedto kill her dog and nearly her son when she’s
possessed by this monster from her child’sbedtime story. This one is going to open
up an interesting can of worms… or perhaps Ishould say “bowl of worms” because the monster
is a metaphor for her grief and depression,which she’s unable to get under control.
So on one hand, she can’t use the puppetexcuse, all of her actions are actuallycoming from her.
She didn’t get a handleon her grief, so it’s her fault.
However, you could make the argument that she isjust a victim of the circumstances.
Yes, she’s mentally ill, but it largelystems from her husband’s unexpecteddeath.
She didn’t ask for any of it, isit really her fault that she’s struggling?
Personally, I think you have to hold heraccountable for what she did.
If you givea pass to everyone who does somethingbad and blames it on mental illness,
then every criminal is going to use that excuse.
In fact, you already see that happening.
Seemslike every apology video these days pullsthe mental illness card. Now that’s not to
say that those people don’t deal with mental
health problems. And I’m not trying to say
that it isn’t a real issue. But think about
it like this. There are plenty of people with
grief and depression who don’t try to kill their
dog and son. If you have mental issues that you
feel are controlling your behavior, it should
be your responsibility to get a hold of it.
–[Amelia] If you touch my son again I’ll f*cking kill you!
But when it comes to puppet villains,
itdoesn’t always have to be a supernaturalpuppeteer.
Take Stu Macher, from Scream.
He was roped into a murder scheme when his
high school friend tried to get revenge on his
father’s adulterous mistress and her daughter.
–[Sidney] What’s your motive?
–[Stu] Peer pressure. I'm far too sensitive.
But none of the puppet villain answerswere upvoted as much as this one.
“Jaws. He was just living hisbest life doing what sharks do.”
True. True! Boy’s gotta eat.
That’s our next category.
♪ Surf Music ♪
We all know who Jaws is, right?
Do I have toexplain that one? He’s a shark that ate somepeople.
This is actually the answer thatinspired me to create different categoriesfor this video.
That, and the fact that Icrave structure in my life, and in my videos.
There are plenty of examples likethis. Many of them are other animals,
who are just naturally hunting to survive.
Ithink someone said the Indoraptor from JurassicWorld.
Jurassic. Boys. Jurassic. Boys! I will
also add the Velociraptors from… Velocicoaster.
I know there’s gonna be somevegan out there who’s like…
– ACKCHYUALLY, allow me to correct you.
But these guys are CARNIVORES,they have to eat meat to survive.
Although the Vegan Velociraptor doessound like a funny comedy sketch.
It’s not just animals though. Severalhorror movie villains that I’ve talkedabout are deities.
Someone mentioned:“Sam from Trick 'r Treat...
He's justthe enforcer of what man created.”
Sam is basically a Halloween spirit
who punishes those who do not adhere to theancient traditions of the holiday, Samhain…
– Sam Hain.
… which was the precursor to our Halloween.
Speaking of people who deserved it,
thischaracter named Emma tries to take the Halloween
decorations down ON THE NIGHT OF, then says this…
–[Emma] I hate Halloween.
Nobody could possibly be considered in the wrongfor murdering this b***h.
Similarto Sam (and also made by the samedirector) we have Krampus.
Instead ofenforcing traditions of Celtic folklore,
Krampus hails from Alpine and Nordic legends and
protects the ancient traditions around Christmas.
Someone on Threads mentioned The Killer Klowns
from Outer Space, arguing that we eat things
less intelligent than we are, so why shouldn’tthey?
True! True, but on closer inspection I’m
not sure if we should trust this guy becausehe appears to be a Killer Klown from OuterSpace himself.
He might be trying to get usto accept our fate as cotton candy treats.
Another one I thought of is Death from FinalDestination.
You could argue that Death is
not an entity, moreso a concept or force ofnature,
but Death is the closest thing we
have to a villain in most of those movies.
EachFinal Destination film features a character who
has a clairvoyant vision allowing thecharacter to save his or herself and
several others from a horrible disaster.
But,because they were supposed to die that day,
Death keeps coming for them, and they
have to figure out how before it’s…
(Hit by Bus)
…too late.
I have one more example, and while it’s
not the perfect case for virtuous villainy,
it is unique enough to go ina category all on its own.
♪ Spiritual Music ♪
Midsommar is the 2019 folk horror film directedby Ari Aster.
At the beginning of the movie,
the protagonist, Dani Ardor, loses her parents
and sister in a horrible tragedy, and six months
later, her boyfriend invites her to go on a trip
to Sweden to experience the Midsommar festival
at the home village of his friend, Pelle.
Pelleis immediately interested in Dani coming with.
–[Pelle] You know, I’m very, very glad you’re
coming. I think it’s very good you’re coming.
Once there, he teaches Dani about how in their
culture, everything is experienced together,
including emotions like joy and sorrow.
The reason he was excited to have her
on the trip is because she’s beengrieving the loss of her family,
and *his* family can help her bearthe weight of that emotional burden.
The American visitors are shocked anddisgusted when they witness the Ättestupa,
a ritual suicide committed by the village eldersafter reaching age 72. But in their culture,
this is normal, and it’s considered an honor,
because the elders know they will never grow old
enough to where caring for them becomes a burden.
In the end, each of the foreign visitors (otherthan Dani) break one of the cult's rules,
and are offered up as part of a sacrificeat the end of the Midsummer celebration,
while Dani becomes their MayQueen and joins the cult.
We learn that Pelle was planning it from thebeginning.
Their life cycle is broken up intoseasons,
and those aged 18-36 are sent on apilgrimage to meet people outside the family,
and bring them back for the purposesof reproduction with genetic variation,
and, of course, to serve as fresh bloodsacrifices during the burning ritual.
While the international guests were disturbed and
off-put seeing ritual suicide that they weren’t
used to, the cult members seem OK with it.
There’sa whole other debate to be had about the ethics ofeuthanasia.
It is mostly frowned upon throughoutthe world today,
but there are major nations whereit is legal,
like Belgium, Luxembourg, Canada,New Zealand, Spain, the Netherlands and Colombia.
It’s a compelling debate that I’d be interestedto learn more about.
A lot of people online seem to support the idea, but obviously some are
against any form of taking human life.
It reminds me of the abortion debate, only ittakes place on the other end of your life.
But even if we ignore this particularissue, I still can’t say that Pelle
was in the right here. It’s one thingto sacrifice yourself if your culture
is accepting of it. He lost me when hesacrificed his friends, who didn’t know
what they were getting themselves into.
Pelleis definitely in the wrong on this one.
Also,their family intentionally in-breeds one person
who they refer to as their “oracle”, because
they claim that the mental deformities give him
vision that is not clouded by normal cognition.
You’re intentionally giving someone a lifetime
of medical problems. That’s totally f*cked up.
But despite those issues, I think “They WereOnly Bad To Us” is an interesting category,
even though I could only think ofone example, and that one example
doesn’t exactly qualify… If you can thinkof any others, let me know in the comments.
I think the takeaway here is thatmost villains aren’t perfect angels,
and if they were, they wouldn’t really bevillains would they? But the best ones,
the ones that are the most fun to talk about,
are the ones that have people on both sidesof the aisle.
The ones where you *can* have adiscussion that turns into a discussion of ethics.
A lot of YouTubers like to say, “OK, let’s
keep it civil in the comments.” But honestly,
I kinda don’t care. Feel free to ripeach other apart in the comments.
But in my opinion, it isn’t that relevantif the person is actually in the right orin the wrong.
It is those who *think* theyare in the right, or at the very least,
*understand* why they are in the wrong andstill see it fit to just push on anyway,
who make the most compellingand memorable villains.
OK, I was about to finish this video, but
we’ve got a late submission in the 11th hour.
“The Blind Guy from Don’t Breathe.”
Girl. Girl! Do you not rememberthe second half of that movie?
But if you want to understand these morally
ambiguous malefactors on a deeper level, you’re inluck!
Because I’ve already done deep dive analyses
on many of them in my amazing and wonderful show called Horror History.
You’ll find a playlistof everyone I talked about today on the left.
If you love analyzing evil-doers asmuch as I do,
make sure you subscribeto CZsWorld for new horrors every week,
ringthe deathbell and select all notifications, and I will see you in the next one.
Assumingwe both survive.
Ok, now it’s really over.